mesdames mesdemoiselles messieurs
bonjour
comme chaque mercredi il y avait ce
matin un conseil des ministres à
l'elysée un conseil qui s'est terminé
d'ailleurs il y à une vingtaine de
minutes et ce conseil devait être
consacré presque exclusivement aux
affaires internationales mais au dernier
moment ce matin monsieur georges
pompidou et les membres du gouvernement
on tue comme d'ailleurs un certain
nombre d'usagers de la sncf une assez
mauvaise surprise
en effet le mouvement de grève lancé
lundi au dépôt d'achères par un certain
nombre de cheminots s'étaient étendues à
l'appel des dirigeants de la cgt à
d'autres dépôts de la banlieue
parisienne et de la province est ce
vraiment une surprise nous allons voir
dans un instant mais d'abord faisons le
point avec ou en commençant par la gare
saint-lazare claude carré en effet
mauvaise surprise ce matin pour les
voyageurs de banlieue de la gare saint
lazare
de nombreux trains étaient bloqués par
la grève lancé par la seule cgt dans la
nuit d'hier et dans la matinée
d'aujourd'hui les arrêts de travail se
multipliaient après le dépôt d'achères
ceux de saint lazare mantes levallois
argenteuil et montrouge ont cessé le
travail
l'importante perturbations sont prévues
dans la journée sur les réseaux de la
région ouest
perturbations également dans le midi
aujourd'hui les dépôts d'avignon nice
toulon et marseille sont paralysées à
75%
trois trains paris vintimille sont
bloqués à marseille cependant à part
quelques retards dans le trafic
la situation est calme à nîmes perpignan
montpellier narbonne arles et valence
rêve également sur les lignes de la gare
montparnasse
ce matin les trains de banlieue étaient
rares et la ligne paris dreux très
perturbée dès hier soir les cheminots de
la gare de triage de trappes ont cessé
toute activité au moment où la grève est
suivie par 98% des agents le réseau aux
hommes du bus est le plus atteint mais
d'importants retards sont à craindre sur
les grandes mines
à l'heure actuelle certaines régions ne
sont pas touchés par ce mouvement le
service est normal dans le nord en
alsace dans la région de lyon et dans
les grandes villes à toulouse nantes
rennes rouen et bordeaux
cependant si vous devez prendre le train
il est préférable que vous puissiez vous
renseigner dans les gares pourquoi cette
grève lancé par la seule cgt et bien
françois gourd la réponse à cette
question se trouvait peut-être désir
matin dans un article de l'humanité un
article signé georges
oui c'est exact le secrétaire général de
la cgt écrivait tout cela alourdit le
climat social il ya du mécontentement
dans l'air le gouvernement et le
patronat serait bien avisé d'en prendre
conscience et d'examiner sérieusement
avec les organisations syndicales
les mesures à prendre fin de citation
solide et ceci dit il ne s'agit pas dit
laisse d'une grève surprise puisqu'en
fait c'est de la menace posée depuis
plusieurs semaines il a noté que
l'association était seul à l'organiser
les autres syndicats estiment que avant
de déclencher un mouvement de grève
il faut aller au bout de la négociation
or actuellement négocié oui c'est
notamment une surprise en fait cette
grève que les négociations doivent
reprendre demain avec la guerre les
négociations reprennent demain et
s'achève demain vous je lui ai expliqué
en gros comment ça se passe vous savez
que à la sncf a proposé un contrat aux
fédérations syndicales de cheminots ce
contrat porte sur plusieurs points
salaire 5 points 50% d'augmentation en
70 qu'ont lieu durée du temps durée du
travail réduction de la durée du travail
pardon 1h30
d'ici le 1er janvier 71 enfin pas de
limitation du droit de grève et en
échange de quoi la direction sncf
demanderai aux fédérations syndicales
d'admettre que le progrès nécessite une
réduction d'effectifs de 50 d'humidité
alors actuellement les syndicats
étudient ses compositions la cfdt force
ouvrière par exemple estiment qu'il ya
des éléments nouveaux
mais la cgt d'emblée les a repoussés en
les jugeant insuffisantes
or c'est dommage justement que les
syndicats doivent dire s'ils acceptent
ou s'il refuse la proposition des sens
les propositions de la sncf
en fait ça a rien à dire que demain la
discussion sera extrêmement serré qu'il
s'agit presque d'une négociation de la
dernière chance
nous suivrons bien sûr de très près ces
négociations encore des protestataires à
bordeaux cette fois et c'est le rtf qui
était visé visé par une trentaine de
jeunes gens et de jeunes filles qui
tenait absolument à s'exprimer
hier soir vers 19h15 dans le cadre de
leur semaine d'actions une trentaine de
jeunes gens antimilitariste appartenant
au comité de soutien aux insoumis ont
manifesté dans les locaux du rtf rue
lise gayant à bordeaux après avoir
pénétré dans le bâtiment les
manifestants ont occupé durant près
d'une heure les couloirs de la direction
quatre de leurs délégués ont été reçus
par monsieur jean hébert directeur
régional et monsieur rémy champenois
responsable du bureau régional
d'information qui ont entendu leurs
revendications l'occupation de
contestataires semblant de voir
s'éterniser les forces de police sous
les ordres de monsieur campait
commissaire centrale ont évacué les
jeunes gens et les ont conduits à
l'hôtel de police où ils ont fait
l'objet d'un contrôle d'identité
placé en garde à vue les manifestants
ont été relâchés ce matin décidément
toutes les manifestations de ce genre se
ressemblent quelques remous à la
dernière réunion du conseil
d'administration du district de la
région parisienne les conseillers ont
adopté un certain nombre de mesures
proposées par le ministre de
l'équipement monsieur albin chalandon
mais le rapporteur du projet monsieur
boscher député eu des airs de l'essonne
a démissionné en quête de daniel brême
monsieur bauchet vous étiez rapportèrent
au conseil d'administration du district
de paris il vous avez démissionné je
voudrais savoir pourquoi parce que 10
vue là moment dans la discussion au sein
de la majorité où visiblement on voulait
me mettre un peu en porte à faux avec
moi même j'avais pris des positions
assez durs à l'égard du premier projet
j'ai obtenu je dois le dire je m'en
félicite certain nombre
d'assouplissements de la part du miz de
l'équipement qui je crois c'est rendu
assez largement à mes raisons mais j'ai
eu affaire à un certain nombre de
collègues qui voulaient qui voulait en
quelque soit rattrapé le temps perdu et
aller au delà et me mettre en
contradiction avec ma mère je fais mon a
levé tout simplement
il reste un point important qui n'a pas
été résolu c'est un des points de
réticences que j'avais encore qui était
celui de la protection de gaz hors des
villes nouvelles c'est une nouvelle qui
coûte beaucoup d'efforts et beaucoup
d'argent doivent me semble-t-il avoir
une certaine protection à leur père y
fit
pour éviter que des promoteurs voir les
promoteurs commerciaux s'installent en
grand nombre profiter des équipements
pays en quelque sorte par les deniers
publics et sans bourse délier vient de
faire une bonne affaire
monsieur poirier président et rapporter
un exceptionnel du schéma directeur de
la région parisienne explique à quoi
sert ce document c'est un document qui
coordonne le développement de toute
notre région qui comporte à l'heure
actuelle 9 millions d'habitants comme
vous le savez et qui prévoit qu'en l'an
il pourrait y avoir environ 14 millions
de paris sia qu il faut aussi veiller à
ce que le développement urbain
n'envahissent pas tout l'espace qui
devait les espaces verts est donc
nécessaire que nous maîtrisions le
destin de notre ville et c'est pour cela
que l'on fait un schéma directeur et
c'est pour cela que les mêmes problèmes
se reposant ailleurs les mêmes problèmes
se reposer shire et certaines grandes
métropoles françaises comme marseille
par exemple sont désormais dotés d'un
schéma directeur
bon alors sur le poulet vous prendre un
exemple précis sur cette carte
le grand mal à éviter c'est que ne se
développe autour de paris une espèce de
croûtes d'urbanisation et de maisons
d'où l'idée de concentrer les
développements sur un salon deux points
forts vous les voyez ici trappe
cergy pontoise la ville nouvelle de la
vallée de la marne le grand moulin de
demain evry petites bourses et aux
sources et 5 centres que doivent
normalement se reporter les principales
activités et les principaux centres
d'habitat de la région parisienne pour
éviter quoi c'est que les habitants de
plus en plus nombreux ne soient obligés
de traverser et de franchir des
distances il fait moins considérable
pour se rendre de leur maison à leur
lieu de travail
autrement dit faut synchroniser les
moyens de desserte et le transport avec
développement de l'habitat
prenez par exemple cergy pontoise ville
nouvelle où viennent d'inaugurer une
nouvelle préfecture
eh bien il faudra et c'est ce que nous
comptons faire dans le cadre du 6ème
plein il faudra développer des moyens de
transport en commun et des autoroutes
qui raccorde cergy pontoise à paris mais
il faudra aussi éviter que l'on soit
obligé le passé par le centre de parie
de manière à ce que l'ensemble ne soit
pas véritablement enkystée et pour ce
live organisé avec tardi polycentrisme
pour que toute la vie urbaine de l'an
2000 se passe dans les espaces beaucoup
plus
et beaucoup plus vivant que ce qu'a été
la banlieue de l'entre-deux-guerres
est ce que vous pensez aux poumons de
ceux qui vont habiter par là à la sortie
du nouveau métro métro que presque
général tu être inauguré à
boissy-saint-léger
c'est là que monsieur chalandon espère
acquérir en faisant jouer les mécanismes
la loi foncière acquérir 3300 hectares
de parc pour réaliser quelque chose tu
ferais le premier grand parc public créé
depuis une centaine d'années dans la
région parisienne
à deux pas de la capitale est l'une des
grandes innovations du schéma directeur
il faut aussi souligner c'est la
création de bases de loisirs ça c'est
hélas évidemment tous les 14 millions de
personnes qui vont habiter à l'intérieur
de cette région
mais il faut que cette région et des
axes de communication vous me direz il
ya déjà des autoroutes avec l'ensemble
des autres régions de france alors
est-ce que vous là aussi le schéma
directeur et des prévisions
il ya une petite contradiction
effectivement entre le schéma directeur
qui était pensé uniquement à l'échelle
parisienne au démarrage et qu'on n'a pas
raccordés classe est la france et c'est
pour ça vous assistez maintenant à une
sorte de conflit entre les tenants du
schéma directeur et les parisiens qui
sont violemment parisien et le ministère
qui par vocation ce tour de lance de la
nation
et c'est ainsi qu'on a pu contester la
nécessité de faire cette autoroute que
vous voyez ici qui leur accorderaient
paris à poitiers et ultérieurement à
bordeaux pour la contester pourquoi
c'est parce que les grands axes de
développement de la région parisienne
tels qu'ils figurent au schéma directeur
ne comporte aucun développement urbain
du côté de cette autoroute qui reste
dans le sud-ouest de la france ici pour
nous c'est le désert ce no man's land
d'où l'idée qu' il n'est pas opportun
pour nous de financer sur les crédits de
la région parisienne une autoroute qui
dans le fond une autoroute nationale ni
même son raccordement à l'intérieur de
paris
car pour nous il ya d'autres priorités
qui sont le développement des moyens
publication desservant ce qu'ils vont
nous et leur avenir
au fond ce schéma directeur jusqu'à
présent c'était un peu la lettre au père
noël on demandait tout ce qu'on
souhaitait maintenant eh bien c'est
devenu une page avec des additions
correspondant aux possibilités
financières en fonction des besoins
présenté par les élus de la région
parisienne ce sera peut-être plus
efficace à l'elysée hier soir c'était
soirée de gala 60 ambassadeurs
ministre plénipotentiaire chargé
d'affaires étaient les invités de
monsieur et madame pompidou
les diplomates du moyen-orient d'iran
d'irak de l'arabie saoudite de
l'afghanistan ainsi que les
représentants des états de l'amérique du
sud
les ambassadeurs du mexique et d'espagne
ceux des pays d'extrême orient ainsi que
les ambassadeurs de plusieurs états
africains étaient hier soir parmi
d'autres délégations une soixantaine
environ les autres donneurs du second
dîner offert par monsieur georges
pompidou
c'est dans le salon des ambassadeurs que
le président de la république en habit
la poitrine bardée du grand cordon de la
légion d'honneur et madame pompidou ont
accueilli les diplomates parmi les
invités outre les membres du
gouvernement français vous allez voir
monsieur alain poher se trouvaient les
représentants des quatre grand monsieur
wang chen ambassadeur de chine populaire
monsieur serge leiber ambassadeur des
etats-unis christopher somme
représentant de la grande bretagne et
monsieur valéry noreen que vous allez
voir également ambassadeur de l'union
soviétique
la table était dressée dans la petite
salle des fêtes du palais présidentiel
elle comptait pour ce prestigieux dîner
196 couvert une nouvelle venue de bound
mine ce matin les affaires
internationales monsieur willy brandt le
chancelier d'allemagne fédéral a accepté
en effet l'invitation de son collègue
allemand monsieur willy stuff la
rencontre entre les deux chefs de
gouvernement allemand aura lieu à berlin
c'est un évènement considérable elle
aura lieu cette rencontre dans la
deuxième semaine de mars
vraisemblablement et cette année
réellement très considérable car c'est
la première fois depuis la fin de la
deuxième guerre mondiale depuis 1945
donc une rencontre a lieu entre les deux
chefs de gouvernement allemand au proche
orient
une semaine après le bombardement de
lusine d'abou zaabal on assiste
aujourd'hui à une offensive diplomatique
des dirigeants israéliens pour arriver à
une solution négociée du conflit de
voler à cette offensive tout d'abord
celle de madame gold amer le premier
ministre israélien qui devant la knesset
a déclaré nous proposons des
négociations entre égaux et dans le
plein respect des souverainetés
nationales
madame r ajouté nous sommes prêts à
respecter le cessez le feu mais il faut
que nasser le respecte également
deuxième volet à cette offensive
monsieur abba eban le ministre des
affaires étrangères israélien se trouve
en visite à la haye où il a rencontré
monsieur delon le premier ministre
néerlandais
monsieur abba eban a proposé que soit
organisée une conférence internationale
avant même que la paix ne soit rétabli
au proche orient
cette conférence devra résoudre le
problème des réfugiés palestiniens
il s'est cependant prononcé contre le
retour pur et simple des réfugiés en
territoire israélien
monsieur abba eban a également déclaré
nous sommes disposés à négocier tous les
poids en litige
mais pour monsieur tente le secrétaire
général des nations unies la situation
est de plus en plus préoccupante au
proche orient après avoir reçu à new
york monsieur aux bulles le chef des
observateurs des nations unies et s'est
entretenu à genève avec monsieur godard
jean celui qui fut pendant plusieurs
mois mais sans résultat le médiateur
entre israéliens et arabes
monsieur tente lui a demandé de
reprendre sa mission en israël les
commandos palestiniens continuent à
attaquer les mouches avaient les
kibboutz c'est ainsi qu'à nos bus de
katusha est tombé sur l'une des maisons
de dixon ne causant que des dégâts
matériels mais c'est toujours sur le
canal de suez que la situation est la
plus vive
aujourd'hui l'aviation égyptienne a
attaqué à deux reprises des positions
israéliennes près d'el kantara tel aviv
affirme qu'il n'ya aucune victime la
visite à londres de monseigneur marty
l'archevêque de paris n'a pas plu à tous
les anglais tout cela parce que le
prélat français a été reçu par la reine
elizabeth d'angleterre et c'est ainsi
qu'on a vu fleurir des slogans à bas les
papistes à bas la papauté devant les
grilles de buckingham palace soit 6 et
anglais qui protestent contre la venue
de monseigneur martin vous incendie
cette nuit dans la région parisienne a
besoin dans la banlieue de paris cette
nuit les pompiers de toutes les casernes
du val d'oise ont été mobilisés pour
combattre un gigantesque incendie à
l'usiné la cellophane
des flammes de plusieurs dizaines de
mètres une fumée opaque c'est ce que
l'on pouvait voir cette nuit à bezons il
a fallu plus de dix heures d'efforts aux
pompiers pour se rendre maîtres du feu
qui s'est déclaré ce matin vers 1h dans
une usine de textile synthétique
artificielle de bezons 10 heures de
lutte acharnée pour cent pompiers qui
avaient mis en batterie 25 grosses
lances et quatre lances à grande
puissance
actuellement les pompiers sont maîtres
du peu mais le feu n'est pas encore
totalement et taille ne le sera
probablement pas avant le milieu de
l'après midi c'est dans un bâtiment où
sont stockés des cuves de solvants que
l' incendie s'est déclaré
deux des cuves ont explosé rapidement le
feu s'est communiqué à deux autres
bâtiments
ces bâtiments où son temps proposé trois
mille tonnes de matières inflammables
servant à la fabrication du plastique se
sont effondrés et sept au total une
superficie de 4000 mètres carrés qui a
été ravagé cet incendie gigantesque dont
on ne connaît pas encore les causes n'a
fait heureusement aucune victime
nous allons parler sport dans un instant
mais d'abord de petites communication
tout d'abord la direction d'electricité
de france nous demande de signaler que
toutes les personnes qui dans le
cotentin dans les régions où
l'électricité n'a pas encore été
rétablie se servent d'un groupe
électrogène l'edf leur demande de
téléphoner à l'edf pour leur signaler
c'est pour une raison technique une
raison de sécurité maintenant dit
d'autre part françois gauche 3 vous avez
les dernières nouvelles sur la grève de
la sncf
oui il s'agit d'un communiqué du
syndicat national des usagers des
transports
je cite soucieux de défendre les
intérêts des usagers le snu tu regrettes
une fois de plus que les grèves se soit
déclenchée à l'improviste à la sncf
mettant dans le plus grand embarras de
très nombreux travailleurs subitement
privées de leurs moyens de déplacements
habituels
je crois que c'est un point de vue qu'il
fallait préciser les classes sport donc
une victoire française en basket il hier
soir à vichy le club local de vichy donc
s'est qualifié pour les quarts de finale
de la coupe des coupes de basket
européen en battant l'équipe belge du
standard de liège quarts de finale de la
coupe d'europe des vainqueurs de coupes
en basket hier dans la salle des ailes à
vichy ce col marque pour les thermaux
que nous reconnaissons en blanc face au
standard de liège à droite maillot
sombre au match aller en belgique le
score avec et nuls 95 partout mais
devant 2000 personnes les vichyssois
vont prendre le match en main après dix
minutes de jeu
cette attaque tesnière s'ouvre aux
naines ne va rien donner
le contre local sa rapide efficace
tentative de bennett sur service
jacquemod robertson est là pour marquer
un nouveau panier treize points d'écart
donc à la mi-temps la zone press de dc a
fait son effet ville est là mais ce
thème hier ce sous l'éteignoir et sans
leurs passeurs les convie cachera pen ne
feront pas la loi dans les deux
raquettes ou trio skol bennett roberson
est roi la balle tourne vite à la jab et
après ces combinaisons besson bennett
jacquemod robertson bennett l'unique est
à la conclusion les plaindre est assez
oui qui ont fait le trou jusqu'à 34
points d'écart on ne reconnaît plus les
belges accablé certes andriat the witch
peut respirer
la qualification est là tout réussit à
vichy qui va encore marqué par ce col
très brillant
78 53 10 6 qualifie pour les demi
finales de cette coupe d'europe
oui c'était effectivement les
demi-finales et non pas les quarts de
finale comme je les taquine alexandre
pour commencer cette partie magazine je
crois que vous avez une bonne nouvelle à
annoncer aux automobilistes parisiens
oui serons très contents si vous
empruntez l'autoroute du sud
vous aurez l'occasion d'expérimenter un
nouveau système de délestage en cas
d'embouteillage qu'un reportage de jean
pierre delgado nous allons voir tout
d'abord présenté par michel toulouse une
nouvelle berline lancer sur le marché
automobile
lewin nouvelle naissance dans la classe
des berlines moyennes son père le groupe
roots dont dépend 5 bimla baptisé à
wenger vengeurs elle est d'une
génération la concurrence est vive
ses petits camarades renault 12 peugeot
304 ou ford escort l'attend de pied
ferme
la nouvelle n'est pas 860 kg elle peut
avoir deux moteurs 12150 points 15
centimètres cubes
et puisqu'il faut tout prévoir en cas
d'accident la carrosserie se déforme en
absorbant le choc
et bien que ce vengeurs viennent d'un
pays plat et froid c'est à malte que la
petite dernière de chez route ou zend et
chrysler a fait sa première apparition
malte peut-être pour caler les qualités
guerrières des chevaliers afin
d'affronter la concurrence et leur
générosité quant à sa capacité
intérieure
et peut-être verra-t-on cette nouvelle
automobile sur l'autoroute du sud en
bourgogne au moment des vacances
vaughn qui sera peut-être la région la
moins aboutie de france grâce à
l'électronique sur les routes à forte
densité de circulation sont placés des
palpeurs incrustés au bitume sous forme
de film magnétique est relié à des
capteurs ces capteurs transmettent par
ont de courtes un ordinateur situé au pc
de l'autoroute de pouilly en auxois les
renseignements concernant la densité de
circulation l'état des routes et tous
les impondérables qui pourrait rendre
difficile l'écoulement des véhicules
si par exemple l'autoroute a6 est très
encombré l'ordinateur effectué lui-même
sans l'aide de l'homme les changements
de direction nécessaires sur la
nationale 6 par exemple toutes les
opérations effectuées par l'ordinateur
sont reçus par télex opc d'autoroute où
elles sont interprétées en clair ceux
qui permettent aux responsables de la
circulation de rectifier si l'ordinateur
fait une erreur
et pour les automobilistes voici de
manière concrète comment leur apparaîtra
l'opération pouilly changement a vu des
panneaux indicateurs sur l'autoroute
permettant le dégagement sur des routes
moins encombré
l'opération pouilly peut-être un remède
contre les crises de nerfs au volant la
maison individuelle favorise un style de
vie que le français apprécie
profondément sa correspondance ont
besoin de liberté d'indépendance et
d'intimité
malgré les servitudes que cela implique
aussi un reportage de france vérité des
images de serge van der wiel maisons
individuelles dont vous voyez ici
quelques maquettes seront construites en
trois ans sur l'ensemble du territoire
français par sept groupes retenus au
terme des épreuves du concours de la
maison individuelle
lancée le 31 mars 1969 par monsieur
albin chalandon ministre de l'équipement
et du logement
ce concours devait permettre de rendre
la maison individuelle accessible au
plus grand nombre aux travailleurs aux
jeunes ménages et d'autre part devait
favoriser la naissance d'un nouvel
urbanisme
c'est ainsi que des villages de maisons
individuelles seront construits
notamment dans la région parisienne
ainsi que dans le nord pas de calais et
dans le midi cela semble correspondre
aux goûts des français qui pour une
majorité d'entre eux souhaitent ou
préfèrent habiter en maison individuelle
ceci principalement pour des raisons
familiales
madame ya longtemps que vous habitez
hi-fi l'a31 et vous avez choisi de vivre
dans une
dans ma vision oui parce que au point de
vue des enfants c'est beaucoup plus
agréable
ne serait-ce que de pouvoir les laisser
se promener en plein été ou de les
mettre lorsqu'ils sont tout petits dans
leur voiture les laisser dormir que de
les descendre dans la rue lorsqu'on est
en appartement et de les mettre au
contact des voitures et puis malgré tout
pour le mari lorsqu'ils rentrent le soir
s'il est dans un bureau il est agréable
de pouvoir rester dehors le soir tard
qu'un appartement il n'est pas possible
même si on a un petit balcon
messieurs il ya longtemps que vous
habitez ici il ya deux ans et demi et
pourquoi avez vous choisi de vivre dans
une maison ici
eh bien nous avions eu envie avec ma
femme de d'avoir de la place d'abord ce
qui est très important d'avoir un petit
peu de l'espace vital pour les enfants
nous avons un petit jardin j'avais très
envie de pouvoir le garder ma voiture le
soir la nuit le jour à n'importe quelle
heure et évidemment c'est très facile
avec un pavillon
quels sont les inconvénients y en at il
oui il ya des inconvénients oui
il faut entretenir sa maison évidemment
alors il faut être pas trop faire un peu
de menuiserie nous avons même fait le
carrelage de la salle à manger ma femme
et moi mois de septembre
il faut toucher un petit peu à tout
comment vous organisez-vous dans votre
vie quotidienne les courses etc
le fait d'habiter un pays où il pose des
problèmes pour les courses parce que
nous n'avons pas commerçants à proximité
alors personnellement je faisais le
marché deux fois par semaine quand je ne
travaillais pas l'effet que je travaille
je le fais une fois par semaine et une
fois par mois je prends mon épicerie et
tout ce qui peut faire de moi et d'autre
part est-ce que vous avez beaucoup de
relations avec les personnes de votre
rue ce que vous connaissez
alors nous nous voyons surtout l'été
parce que tout le monde est à
l'extérieur tout on travaille son jardin
le samedi et de dimanche on se parle
volontiers on est on vit pas mal dehors
l'été
alors on a beaucoup plus de relation
d'aidé poussins il est sûr que l'hiver
on se voit très peu genre né à nos
conseillers psychologiques à l'école des
parents anne marie coutrot rédacteur en
chef de la revue de l'école des parents
en france on dit quelquefois que les
grandes villes sondées d'immenses
banlieue peuplés d'anciens paysans et
c'est pas pour rien que l'ancien paysan
a besoin de retrouver sa terre et dès
qu'il le peut même dans un immeuble
collectif
s'il peut avoir une résidence secondaire
wendy jardins et annexe
ils choisissent la l'attachement à la
terre ça une certaine importance
oui moi je trouve que c'est plus
tellement latins enfin nuit peut-être
attachement à l'interné je crois que le
français l'homme en général ou la
famille
vous voulez a besoin d'un certain espace
pour vivre et s'organiser à l'intérieur
de cet espace
selon son propre rythme familial selon
ses libertés
c'est un enfant fait et c'est une façon
pour elle d'exprimer une certaine
liberté
on se sent insécurisés non seulement qui
nous oppresse un peu dans le monde du
travail
tandis que là on va retrouver des
valeurs affectives des valeurs
familiales et la famille va peut-être
espère ton plus se retrouver quand les
gens se sont fixés ont planté leur ce
prix qu'elle n'est resté à s'enraciner
et à manger leur cerise et on peut
penser que ça va à l'encontre d'une
certaine mobilité et de l'emploi et de
l'habitat que cette succession la maison
individuelle il semble que la structure
familiale s'améliore dans la maison
individuelle mais enfin c'est peut-être
une vue de l'esprit enfin c'est
peut-être simplement en nous fait que la
maison individuelle correspond à quelque
chose que nous souhaitons profondément
mais que nous pourrions peut-être trouvé
dans un immeuble collectif aussi c'est
une question d'éducation beaucoup et
c'est aussi une question de tradition
le débat reste ouvert michel tardieu
vais-je gagne en bourse de quoi
m'acheter une maison individuelle mais
j'aurais voulu vous rassurer la clinique
sainte parce que je vous sens anxieuse
de voir comment évolue votre
portefeuille
mais je dois avouer que la bouche encore
aujourd'hui s'effrite
ce n'est pas très étonnant parce que
nous sommes à la séance de la réponse
des primes c'est à dire que tous les
gens qui ont acheté des primes pendant
le mois boursier doivent dire si il
l'élève c'est à dire s'ils prennent
livraison des titres qu'ils ont acheté
ou si au contraire ils abandonnent leurs
primes
et comme la bourse a baissé depuis une
quinzaine de jours beaucoup